[Musik]
das ganze können wir einordnen mit Egon
Rams Nato-General ade general guten
Morgen schön dass Sie bei uns sind
schönen guten Morgen ja wir lassen Sie
uns sprechen über die Frühjahrsoffensive
der Ukraine laut den Worten des
Verteidigungsministers reisnikow
befindet sich diese in der Endphase
welches Szenarien sind denkbar ihrer
Meinung nach also ich denke mal dass sie
in der Endphase der Vorbereitung ist und
dass er das auch damit gemeint hat das
heißt die Vorbereitungen sind nach
seiner Auffassung soweit abgeschlossen
es gibt mehrere Möglichkeiten man greift
im Osten dann zweite Möglichkeit man
versucht in den Richtung Süden auf die
Krim zuzustoßen dritte Möglichkeit man
versucht die in Teilen durch Russland
besetzten Regionen unten im Süden das
heißt insbesondere den Anschluss nach
Don jetzt und unten nach der Paris ja in
irgendeiner Form zu teilen dabei taucht
oft der Name militopol auf dass man in
diese Richtung angreifen könnte ich
halte das im Augenblick alles noch ein
bisschen für Spekulation militopol wäre
ein strategisch gute Ansatz einfach aus
strategisch Ansatz wenn man damit unten
die russisch besetzten Gebiete teilen
könnte und möglicherweise auch die Krim
unter Druck setzen können das Wetter
wird sicherlich auch eine Rolle spielen
wann denken sie startet diese
angekündigte Offensive also man braucht
für die Radfahrzeuge aber auch für die
gepanzerten Kettenfahrzeuge braucht man
einen entsprechenden festen Untergrund
der offensichtlich noch nicht sage ich
mal komplett wieder abgetrocknet ist und
von daher ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten
verursacht wenn die Ukraine Bilder
vermeiden wollen wie wir sie letztes
Jahr gesehen haben als die Russen auf
Kia von Norden angegriffen haben 60 km
Schlange auf der Straße und viele Panzer
im Sumpf dann werden Sie sicherlich noch
ein paar Tage warten aber ich denke mal
irgendwann so in 14 Tagen wird das
möglich sein wobei ganz deutlich gesagt
eine Vorhersage wann die nun anfangen
traurig mir nicht zu und sollen wir
wahrscheinlich auch nicht wissen so ist
militärisch geschickt Alter
ukrainische Präsident selenski am
Wochenende noch mal zu Wort gemeldet und
gesagt diese Offensive werde starten
auch ohne all die versprochenen
Waffenlieferungen oder schweres Gerät
was zugesagt wurde wie würden Sie denn
beurteilen wir die Ukraine aufgestellt
aufgestellt ist aktuell was von dem was
versprochen wurde ist tatsächlich schon
angekommen was fehlt noch also es gibt
einige ich sage das mal besonders
herausragende Stücke die angekommen sind
das ist beispielsweise der britische
Challenger Panzer Challenger 2 das ist
beispielsweise der Leopard 2 der aus
Deutschland gekommen ist
sind aber vielleicht noch genauso
wichtig weitere Artilleriegeschütze
Raketenwerfer beispielsweise
amerikanische heilmaß die zusätzlich
gekommen sind aber wesentliche Teile wie
beispielsweise die von Deutschland auch
mal angesprochen Leopard 185 und das war
eine erhebliche Stückzahl die irgendwo
ich sag mal oberhalb 150 liegen könnte
fehlen nach wie vor und die Masse dieser
Panzer werden auch erst im ersten im
nächsten Jahr geliefert werden darüber
muss man sich im Klaren sein das heißt
das ist etwas was wir oft vergessen dass
zwischen Entscheidung und Ansage ein
erheblicher Zeitraum vergeht bis
praktisch die Panzer dann tatsächlich in
der Ukraine Verf sind inklusive Munition
Instandsetzung alles was dazugehört und
ich nehme mal die M1 abbrems die die
Amerikaner zugesagt haben wenn man
Kenntnisstand richtig ist a von denen
bisher gar keiner in der Ukraine und wie
ich das richtig weiß werden die auch
erst im Januar Februar nächsten Jahres
kommen wenn man das hört was sie gerade
beschreiben fragt man sich weshalb die
Ukraine sich trotzdem bereit für diese
Frühjahrsoffensive zu starten also wie
gerade auch aus ihrem Bericht
hervorgegangen ist sind offensichtlich
die westlichen Waffensysteme in diesem
Falle bei dem Thema Atelier zum Teil
aber auch bei der Flugabwehr
den russischen Waffensystem doch ich sag
mal in einigen Teilen erheblich
überlegen und von daher macht man
möglicherweise mit weniger Waffensystem
erreicht man die gleiche Wirkung wie sie
die Russen mit viel Material Erreichen
von daher kann man das möglicherweise
versuchen wichtig ist dass der ukalische
Generalstab dabei immer versucht seine
Truppen so aufzustellen dass er eine
örtliche Überlegenheit erreichen kann
wenn man es Angreifer und als jemand der
in die Offensive schon vorrücken will
braucht man schon eine Überlegenheit um
den Gegner zu schlagen dann schauen wir
mal auf die andere Seite auf die
russische Seite da hören wir von
britischen Geheimdiensten das
Verteidigungsanlagen ausgehoben werden
und zwar nicht nur an der Front oder in
den von Russland besetzten Gebieten
sondern tatsächlich auch im Land selbst
in Russland selbst
um einen Durchbruch der Ukraine eben zu
verhindern dass letzteres verwundert
einen erstmal also der britische
Geheimdienst ist normalerweise in
solchen Dingen sehr zuverlässig von
daher gehe ich mal davon aus dass er
diese Informationen aus verlässlichen
Quellen hat es scheint tatsächlich so zu
sein dass der ein oder andere ich sag
das mal regionale Befehlshaber auf der
russischen Seite Sorge hat dass er
angegriffen werden könnte oder auch am
Signal zu sitzen nach dem Motto ich bin
ein ganz besonders guter Putin
Unterstützer wird jetzt auf der
russischen Seite werden praktisch
Stellung ausgebaut aber das ist nur ein
lokalen örtlichen Bereichen verstellbar
nicht flächendeckend von daher Ort nicht
das mit einer einer solchen Entwicklung
zu etwas überall übereifrige lokale
Befehl zu haben jetzt hat es am
Wochenende auch noch ein Telefonat
gegeben zwischen Peking und der Ukraine
selensky hat gesprochen und der neue
Außenminister der Ukraine Melnik
beurteilt diese Gespräche als durchaus
oder die die Chancen Chinas als
Vermittler aufzutreten als nicht
unrealistisch oder durchaus realistisch
wie lesen Sie China in diesem Konto es
gibt ja nun es gibt ja nun nicht nur
jeder sondern es gibt ja auch andere
Länder wie beispielsweise Brasilien wie
beispielsweise Indien die ich sag das
mal vorsichtig entweder eine
unterstützende Rolle für Russland
spielen oder zumindest eine neutrale
Rolle die sich noch positionieren müssen
ich glaube dass dieses Gespräch zwischen
dem Präsidenten silenski und dem
Präsidenten Ski ein sehr wichtiges
Gespräch war weil dieser erste Kontakt
nach Beginn des Krieges wichtig war
damit sie vielleicht auch die Situation
in der Ukraine anders einordnen kann als
sie ihm bisher von der russischen Seite
dargestellt worden ist und jeder der
sich um Frieden oder um Verhandlungen
bemüht die auch entsprechend ich sag mal
die rechte und die die Bedingungen der
Ukraine entsprechend reflektieren ist
mir mit willkommen ich brauche keinen
Krieg sage ich mal ganz einfach und
viele andere sicherlich auch nicht aber
es darf wie der Kanzler auch immer sagt
kein diktatfrieden werden wo die Ukraine
von vornherein große Teil ihres
Territoriums abtreten muss
herzlichen Dank für ihre Einordnung dass
sie heute bei uns waren hier im Studium
danke